[Music]
travel ban 3.0 made its way before the
US Supreme Court today as challengers
make the case against the president's
entry restrictions on people from
several Muslim majority countries but as
chief legal correspondent shannon bream
reports several justices seemed
supportive the president Trump has
executive authority over immigration
even the lower courts have struck down
versions of this band three times the
final arguments of the Supreme Court
term the justices hearing one of the
most controversial cases last much of
the argument over the third version of
the president's so-called travel ban
focused on the balance of power between
Congress and the president when it comes
to immigration and vetting justice
Sotomayor asking how far the executive
can go but what I see the president
doing here is saying I'm going to add
more to the limits that Congress set and
to what Congress said was enough where
does the president get the authority to
do more than Congress has already
decided Justice Alito addressed claims
by critics of the ban that it's thinly
disguised religious discrimination
against Muslims I think there are 50
predominantly Muslim countries in the
world five predominantly Muslim
countries are on this list the
population of the predominantly Muslim
countries on this list make up about 8%
of the world's Muslim population and of
course there was plenty of discussion of
the president's previous statements
including one removed from his campaign
website calling for a quote total and
complete shutdown of Muslims entering
the United States until our country's
representatives can figure out what is
going on Chief Justice Roberts asking
the plaintiff's attorney if the travel
ban would be problem-free if the
president simply disavowed his earlier
comments and then reissued the ban did
your answer to my question yes exist the
amaro he issues a proclamation
disavowing those statements absolutely
the court did seem split along
ideological lines and it appears Justice
Kennedy may once again be the swing vote
a decision is do
Lee Joon Brett's shown as the
administration awaits this decision
there's another ruling about daca that
is really raising some eyebrows yes yet
another judge has struck down daca at
least this administration's ability to
put a stop on it and so while other
judges have said you gotta freeze it
where it is now this judge has gone even
further saying not only do you got to
protect the people who are in the
program now you have to start opening it
up to new applications now with that
they gave the administration 90 days to
file a new memo to say why they're
justified and shutting it down so it
won't start for at least 90 days what
this judge is saying you gotta ramp the
program back up and do it soon no
Congress could short-circuit all of this
by doing something but it's not likely
that's gonna happen I wouldn't hold my
breath
yes Shannon thank you we'll see you at
11:00 tonight